sa maman elle me traite comme comme si
c'était une maman et veille sur moi je
ne serais ce que pour venir ici
elle a dit à irin j'y fais bien
attention à elle tu m'appelles souvent
pour savoir comment elle va et elle
prend souvent mes nouvelles
elle me fait des cas là me fait des
petits plats qu'est ce que ça te fait de
voir wayne fait du bien j'aurais doit
aujourd'hui ça fait vingt ans vous ne
vous êtes pas vu les deux ça fait pas un
temps ensuite on s'est croisé de temps
en temps dans des histoires et mais
ouais mais vraiment quelque chose
mais bien sûr que ça me fait quelque
chose parce qu'on est avec une histoire
ensemble ouais pas qu'une histoire on a
vécu un nivellement enfin le changement
de notre vie on l'a vécu tous les deux
ouais je rentre dans les douars qu'est
ce que ça te fait de boire loi n'a
franchement que moi ça me fait plaisir
après c'est vrai que je vais je vois
loana après à travers divers pardon à
travers divers articles que j'ai pu voir
dans la presse à travers instagram et à
travers je prends le dire les frasques
mais les malheurs qui lui arrive et
c'est vrai que ça a le parcours assez
finalement malheureux parce qu'ils
avaient quand même un chemin qui a été
tracé qui avait l'air plutôt que m'a
l'air plutôt magnifique c'est la plus
grande star c'est un trio inhabitat
c'était la première donc effectivement
elle a essuyé les plâtres
après c'est vrai moi je vais je vais
appeler ça une plus une descente aux
enfers parce qu'il ya eu un moment il ya
une montée après il ya fait de la peine
de voir tout ce qui est des réserves non
mais on peut souhaiter cela à personne
ne s'est posé quelque chose ou est ce
que tu me disais mais après moi j'ai
fait ma vie j'ai une femme j'ai des
enfants
mais quand il arrive quelles que soient
les personnes autour de vous qui sont
dans la détresse
bien sûr que ça fait du mal mais il ya
un moment on a envie aussi de voir ces
personnes se prendre en main et tenter
de de prendre le problème à bras le
corps et de le régler moi je considère
encore aujourd'hui et cyril je voulais
déjà dit deux fois que je pense que de
revenir à la télévision après tant de
tout temps de drogue aujourd'hui loana
elle est franchement ça fait longtemps
que je n'ai pas vu aussi bien joli ça me
fait plaisir de le voir comme ça
d'ailleurs
loana et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
ghana où il y avait là nous a demandé de
venir parce que elle voulait aussi
parler de son aventure qu vite pour
sensibiliser aussi des gens qui nous
regardent
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui sa démarche
elle est allée à les scènes
excusez-moi j'ai c'est pas du tout une
attaque personnelle mais le sentiment
que moi j'ai ma et que beaucoup de gens
on sait que loana fait une tentative de
elle va vouloir venir en parler luan a
fait une overdose elle va vouloir venir
en parler la dernière fois j'ai vu un
sketch avec une cible comment elle
s'appelle vous étiez tous les deux bien
et c'est donc c'était un grand moment de
télévision mais c'était un grand moment
ultra pathétique quoi c'était c'était un
sketch l'histoire et j'ai moi j'ai
vraiment le sentiment que le mais la
meilleure des choses à faire c'est de se
faire discrète mais vraiment de faire
une culture une real parce que j'ai eu
d'après ce que j'ai compris à des
problèmes de dépendance d'addiction de
choses comme ça et que c'est pas en
venant sur un plateau télé tous les mois
ou tous les mois je vous entends de
série le dire je trouve qu'elle va mieux
et après il ya un autre problème parce
que je je sais j'ai aidé des gens qui
étaient dans le quitter dans les haies
dans les addictions je sais combien
c'est difficile à la toile a lâchement
j'ai pas besoin de ça lui fait du bien
aussi devenir oui sûrement mais je pense
pour leur établissement sur le long
terme ce n'est pas du tout la meilleure
des choses vous répondez à à chaud
edouard louana qu'il a tort qu'il a tort
moi je fais mon parcours je fais ma vie
ça te gêne à sa gêne en personne que je
viens de parler des sujets dont j'ai
envie
toi ça te fait du bien de dire son
époque c'est un exutoire a besoin
d'armes hier aussi un peu s'est pas de
lumière au mais non c'est être avec nous
parce que je sais que tu nous aimes bien
cette voie là trouver une famille pour
moi ça fait 20 ans que je suis dans le
milieu de la télé donc mois à venir et
jc venir de faire un petit bisou faire
un petit coucou je viens pas non plus
tous les mois
bien sûr je viens vous parler edouard
dire qu' il faut que tu fasses un break
vraiment de quoi de de plusieurs
semaines je sais pas leur établissement
ça peut passer de 12 à 15 à un an il ya
des gens nagent à l'agencé un petit
avait des problèmes de délais soient
peur qu'elle tombe justement le bio et
la gauche verts s'il me faut des projets
oui pour moi faut pour avancer il nous
faut justement des projets et pas
justement quelque chose de plats jijel à
trois projets qui sont dedans pour les
dans les trois prochains mois et
et c'est ça qui me booste qui me donne
envie d'être meilleur qui me donne envie
de l'être plus sportive la barousse de
souffle d'être encore le venir ici tu
étais préparé ça fait du bien aussi je
vois voilà la loi n'a franchement
techniquement ça fait longtemps qu'on
l'a pas vue aussi bien voilà et ça fait
du bien aussi
oui ça me fait du bien ça me motive eux
voilà allez je me laisserais aller et
justement c'est là où ce serait
dangereux tandis que la la je me prépare
là je me fais bella je rejette plus des
steam pour moi et plus de confiance en
moi plutôt que de rester affalé dans un
canapé je préfère venir ici les tu
penses pas qu'il serait qui se serait
mieux de excusez moi de faire un break
et de revenir justement à un moment
donné où tu es tu peux revenir la tête
haute
c'est où j'ai regardé ton instagram cet
après midi et les gens moi même je le
vois depuis que je suis j'ai débarqué
chez cyril et les gens peuvent être
affreusement méchant bon moi aujourd'hui
ça me touche plus ça me fait rigoler
jalousie non mais son pâté je vois les
gens la sur vos réseaux sociaux
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent on a
jamais assez rarement ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas vu luan a autant en forme
mais à la bénisse voilà oui mais est-ce
que c'est vrai que j'en aie dont il est
un peu il est un peu dur mais je
comprends ce qui veut dire c'est pas dur
un peu de bienveillance que j'ai dit
c'est un peu des rentes ont pour moi
j'ai l'impression mais on a fêté les 20
ans étaient ensemble étaient des
retraites soit pas là mais est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas moins il
faut faire le deuil finalement de cette
aventure incroyable qui a été loft il ya
là c'était il ya vingt ans savait il ya
20 ans a construit plein de choses le
chemin que tu as pris en compte parce
qu'il ya une relation très belle fbi
parce que les gens aiment encore
beaucoup mais maintenant il faudrait
qu'on peut être construire quelque chose
de nouveau et passer à autre chose
vraiment et pas revenir sans cesse et
part expliqué le loft est pas parce que
vivent dans le passé malheureusement
parfois ça fait du mal ça fait pas ce
qu'on voit des images parce qu'on on se
projette pas dans le flanc mais je viens
j'ai pas mal du passé puisque je vais
une analyse de ces biens de 2 ha oui
beaucoup pourquoi pour que les choses
aillent non mais je pense que je réponde
pour loana je pense que le loft loana ça
y est elle a complètement oublié là là
là elle quand ils vont mais juste là à l
as dit qu'elle en veut encore de d'avoir
des projets
être encore dans les médias elle pense
qu'elle a encore une place à aller rien
quoi c'est exactement et moi je trouve
que jean edouard et dur parce que loana
aujourd'hui elle est venue nous parler
des autres c'est à dire attention à
l'aco vite faites attention à vous et
c'est la première fois comme ça que vous
entends parler des autres quand on parle
des autres et plus de soi même c'est
qu'on est ouverte
et moi je vous trouve rayonnante mais
c'est vrai je trouve que là vous
irradiés j'ai l'impression que vous êtes
redevenu loana je suis super heureux
super émue de voir comme ça